hey lebron we know how much respect you
have for damian lillard and cj mccollum
and that blazer's backboard what's been
the key defensively in trying to limit
them as the head of the snake there
portland
i'm just following the game plan um you
know as much as those guys make tough
shots you still have to try to
make them take tough shots um you know
you can't pressure them because
they live under the pressure they
succeed under the pressure they thrive
under the pressure
but can't have breakdowns when you have
a defensive
strategy you have to execute that
default strategy for 48 minutes
or for the minutes that they're on the
floor and i think we did a great job
with that tonight
what did you see as the biggest
difference uh in a.d
from game one to game two and how did
you try to help facilitate that starting
in that first quarter
um it was just aggressive um
you know from the beginning of the game
you know it wasn't passive at all
looking for his shots
even somebody that he missed earlier was
uh
the fourth shot and he did a great job
of office rebounding as well but get
some putbacks
in that fashion hey lebron it's dave
how does the uh your guys defensive
effort help this team score
uh on the other end
well that's been one of our stakeholders
all year our defense always a break
here's our offense when we get multiple
stops in a row
we can get out and run our lanes run our
patterns and uh we can either get uh
you know guys flying down and down the
paint for for for dunks and lives and
layups or our shooters shouldn't get
going from the perimeter
um which was the case tonight
ally all right let's start with kyle
goon
lebron obviously portland has had a
really good run
in the bubble and that game won they had
a lot of spirit and how important was it
for you guys to just
kind of kind of crush them a little bit
and
demoralize them i was just one game and
we wanted to execute
about 48 minutes and we felt like we did
a
decent job of executing the first game
besides the opening minutes of the first
six minutes of the first quarter
and then the last six minutes of the
fourth quarter and that's when they they
um they took advantage of us so
uh we knew we had to uh not have as many
defensive laps not many breakdowns
coming into this game
no matter the score which would give us
a better chance while winning the game
time you get gooey um i know that it's
just one game and you've
been through this enough times that you
know not to keep things in perspective a
little bit but
um this was the best your offense is in
the bubble and i wonder
do you think that that was important to
be able to have a game like this and
kind of get
get that back well it's always great to
see the ball go through the rim
but more importantly to defend and i
think
sometimes your defense energizes your
offense but from the beginning of the
game it was great
to see kcp have no um conscience about a
shot
get it going from outside chapelle did
an unbelievable job getting off his
rebound second chance points
and everyone came into the game just
gave us energy and effort and
took it down to everybody that played
tonight
right
when i was asked there did you have any
concern yesterday
when the president urged people to
boycott goodyear
what that you know could mean in the
community uh
i see a lot of a lot of jobs and things
back home there
i know i know my people of akron and i
know
what goodyear means for our city um so
you know one thing about us we we don't
we don't bend and we don't fold and we
don't break from nobody
um so i'm not worried about that
not only has good year been great for my
city
for the history of my city but for the
for the country
and what they what they represented it's
unbelievable
unbelievable brand unbelievable um
history
um so we stand strong and we always
unite especially
my city we've always felt like we've
been counted out
you know being a small city and uh and
that's what rally us even more it makes
us even stronger so
um shout out salute to all the workers
men and women that good year over the
over the course of their history
and into the city to the city
chris maddox when the perimeter shooting
struggles the way it did
you know and restart in game one how
confident are you coming in that
if you keep making the same plays and
keep getting those guys the ball those
shots will
eventually fall because we're confident
when it comes to work ethic and then
when you put in the work
the results will happen if you didn't
put into work that's when you get word
and our shooters our guys put into work
every day
on their shot and um
you know repetition you know you have
repetition you have results
so um never never a doubt in my mind
and uh and we still didn't shoot the
ball extremely well tonight we had some
go in
but um i feel like we're going to get it
going at some point where
everyone is shooting i'm shooting it in
so but um
guys are repping guys are working so
there's no um
nothing to worry about taylor hey lebron
there is a video of you saying we're
built different in the middle of the
game so what are you guys made of i mean
in your opinion what makes you different
from the rest of the league what
separates you from the rest of the
league
um i really don't um
comparison anybody in the league um it's
not what everybody else does
it's not what the the time everyone's
putting in
i just know what type of season we've
had this year
it's been um it's been three or four
seasons
that won we've had a lot of
i mean it started from from training
camp um to pre-season
you know traveling abroad um to entering
the new year
the tragic death obviously of kobe
and those victims on that on that uh
helicopter
to the stop of the season
[Music]
rondo going down for a big big piece of
the year
you know to the restart not having our
brother every bradley here
um and so on and so on i i don't even
know it feels like it's just been like
three or four different seasons so
i know we're capable of i know how we're
built and
i don't compare us to anyone i compare
us to us
and you know i direct that to every one
of our players
because it's not about what everybody
else is doing it's about it's about our
mindset
back to tanisha i think you have the
last couple yes
uh just two more bill gorham
hey lebron um there's there's a debate
that you
that that gets made about whether or not
a.d is the best teammate you've ever had
and i don't expect you to answer that
but for you to have a guy who can carry
the load the way he did tonight
where you play sub 30 minutes only need
to score 10 points and you guys
lead by 30 for much of the second half
um one would you've ever believed that
that would be possible and two
um just what kind of asset is that for
for this team moving forward um
i've had some great teammates in my
career edie is one of those unicorns
and he does things that some of my other
great teammates are not capable of doing
in the same sense um i played with
dwyane wade and
he could do some things that you know
the 80
is not capable of doing and also playing
with kyrie irving
he can do some things that d wade and ad
is not capable of doing
so um i've had the luxury of playing
with some great players and that's just
that's just three of them um but
you know in the presence you know to be
able to go out and uh
you know orchestrate the offensive
orchestrate the tempo and get it to the
hot man get it to a.d
um and and let us run our offense
through him as a luxury for myself as
luxury for our team
um you know i play no pressure
basketball
um i get opportunities to get shots i
get opportunity at lanes i take
advantage of them
um tonight didn't cost for me to do much
offensively or force much
because not only ad had it gone but we
had our shooters going as well
and our bench came in it just gave us a
huge lift so
um you know every game has his own
challenges and tonight
um you know 80 was magnificent and kcp
was
amazing as well last question melissa
lebron uh when guys are making three
pointers how much does it change the
offensive
low and just open things up and change
the rhythm for everybody on the court
oh you just said it um three-point shot
is a
it's a big time shot in our league we've
known that
um obviously the numbers have went up
over the last 10 years but
it's always been a great uh uh you know
shot
you know even in 90s even in the 80s if
you got the ability to shoot the three
um it just spaces the floor um it brings
the defense a little bit closer and
allows your attackers to uh be able to
get into the paint
and do what they do best so um you know
the ability to be able to hit
um you know shots from exterior gave a.d
room
gave myself room gave out a screw show
room uh also gave dwight in javale room
um to be able to work in the paint and
um
you know we want to continue to have
that i want our shooters to continue to
shoot without no conscience
and we're going to continue to give them
the ball no matter make or miss um
and we live with the results okay allie
has one watch
uh taylor you want to follow yeah um so
you're holding autobiography of malcolm
x along with
alex haley i don't know how far you are
into the book but what's your biggest
takeaway so far
um i kind of just started a couple days
ago um
but um i've read and a lot of a lot of
notes over the years
it's my first time actually reading this
from start to finish
which is a very um very smart man
very very very smart man and basically
um
his words in the in the 60s and
uh and what was going on
is actually what's going on today still
him understanding the how powerful
um the negro can be he use that word a
lot
how powerful we are
but we have to unite and we have to be
together we have to stand strong
because there's always going to be
obstacles there's always going to be um
you know things that's going to be
thrown at us where they try to weaken us
um
they try to fill up make us feel like
we're not kings and queens
and it's going to come from all you know
different races and different
shapes and sizes and things of that
nature
and uh just a very powerful minded
uh gentleman and uh
and it's unbelievable to to kind of read
something that's coming directly from
him
um
just hate um wish i had the opportunity
to meet him
obviously we know what with the
situation that happened along
not only him but dr martin luther king
some of the greats has ever walked this
uh
face at earth not only just here in
america but um space that are so
it's a pretty pretty interesting book so
far
thanks so much
alrighty all set tanisha i am ready
we'll start off
hey d it's dave uh we spoke back in in
training camp and you told me that
you want to be in a situation where you
know you play big games and
if you don't show up you know your name
will be
drag through the mud your name will be
in the tabloids and
game one you go eight for 24 you guys
lose
to start the series did you feel any of
of that
kind of kind of pressure that you were
desiring and did it help
your game two performance i was
impressed with myself
um just you know asked a couple guys on
the team
from coaches how can i be better and
they all told me i played well but
just critiquing myself um i knew i could
be better
i'm both dead on the floor and i just
want to come out with the mindset
tonight to be aggressive
and to help my team on both ends of the
floor
and do whatever i have to do to help
what did you see on tape from that first
game about the way that portland was
playing defense
and just how packed into the paint they
were and if there was an adjustment that
you had to make
if at all um well they're packing the
paint because they're forcing us to make
shots
uh and we we didn't make shots game one
um tonight you know god got back and
made some shots and we were able to get
to the point
to the paint then after we seen the ball
you know go from three a couple times
which opens the floor
for everyone um and so we just gotta
stay locked in you know keep taking the
time uh especially when we catch the
ball
on the three and keep it continue to
knock him down once you're gonna open up
the pain for post up so it
um and then when they do come to help
you know making that the right pass the
extra pass to
to open shooters to knock down more
shots so um
the difference in the game was just
johnson then i think we did a great job
defensively
and i think they had 88 points and
there's a team who've been very hot
from three from their range
desperation a sense of urgency on the
defensive end and was able to
try to align those thoughts to find
great points
hey what's the biggest key for you
defensively as the secondary defender on
either lillard or the column
when they're coming off screen roll
action 80 what do you have to focus on
as a helper
being up you know those two guys
especially dane you know like that
that deep ball three um
so just being up trying to take that
away and make those guys
you know beat us with scoring twos um
they're really great three-point
shooting team and you know we just try
to take those shots away
and um you know make somebody else
people but if they do
you know kind of ball in their hands
make them make enforcement to the two
point area and
you know live with a contestant if they
make it then we tip our hats to them but
um you know we really want to take away
the focus on taking away that
ally
you had a couple shots in from mid-range
the first quarter that weren't falling
it seemed like you made a point to kind
of attack the basket more and then that
third quarter
found your touch i think you had that
first position where you dribbled up and
hit the
fight open three does getting to the rim
and sort of getting that touch
um their effect or correlate to
what you can do in your deeper shots
later in the game build your confidence
anything like that
um i just tried to be more aggressive
for taking my time on shots
i felt like a game when i was off
balance about
the two shots i had in the main of the
first quarter i actually liked
inside the paint um i just missed them
and then
just staying confident in my shot you
know honestly um
you know trying to get to the free throw
line and you know and attack the basket
as well
you know i find guys i'll make a play
for myself so just being more aggressive
and not just settling for a jumper but
also into the basket finishing and
playing through contact and i look
forward to
just going to finish and then if they
the red blow whistle then they do if not
you know take my time and finish it and
then they kind of just you know open up
the floor for me
when i'm driving and being able to knock
down a mid-range you know forgot to
kind of fall back a little bit to kind
of stop that which
leaves the three open so just kind of
playing what the defense gives me and
taking the right shots
joe barton you're playing in a game like
that
you're dunking on them you're smothering
them defensively and dame can't get
loose
do you feel the other team's spirit
change
you feel energy start to drain momentum
shifts that kind of thing
um i mean any time you know you're not
performing well
um your energy you know always changes
you know but
you know with us we want to take away
their confidence as early as possible
you know because they can get going very
quickly um especially dane
um and cj and mello you know so
we try to do as much as we can to to
limit those guys early you know if it's
if they coming off shoot you know it's
going to be a tough shot it's going to
be in your face and if you make it then
that's all you wish they can but you
know we have to make sure that we're
doing everything we can
defensively to kind of limit those guys
and you know and also an office event
you know putting them in actions to you
know kind of tie them down because
you know those guys are at least scores
and
as much as we can to you know as they
going
off of the bench our attack up you know
we have to do the same thing and
you know just trying to make a good time
for those guys all night
mark medina yeah when you talk about
playing
aggressively in games are there things
you do in particular
during the day as far as your routine or
previous warm-up they think it's pretty
instrumental
to get you in that move um
nothing really changes
[Music]
my routine has always been the same so
there's nothing that really changed uh
you just i'm not going down and doing it
you know and
i think i know i mean especially brown
you know he didn't say one word to me
today
but he kind of already i mean he kind of
knew he saw the look on my face from the
beginning
but it's just a matter of going out and
doing it you know and just playing a lot
of energy and effort what you can
control
you know i'm controlling how hard i play
how much effort i'll play with i can't
control about
you know shots being made um but i can
control
how i put on the defensive end and
control my energy enough
all right tinisha did you have a few on
your end yeah last three
melissa hey d um
mentally speaking with everything going
on did you feel like you needed the
performance like this and the team
needed to win like this
i feel like we needed to win you know we
don't want to go down 0-2 in the series
and
you know our entire mindset the entire
season has been
i'll never lose two in a row and we just
wanted to come out
very scrappy you know kind of the same
way we did in game one
and just have a lot of confidence in
making shots but
you know you never want to go down over
20 series and
you know it was a a must win game for us
and we played that way
play with a sense of desperation and a
sense of urgency and
like i said to be able to hold that team
you know the 88 points who've been
playing extremely well in this bubble
you know obviously rating is off the
charts
you know it's it's it's great for our
team pray for our defense but
you know it's still one game and um
we got three games to go or three more
wins to go
and we just want to make sure we come up
with the same energy we did tonight
anthony you you mentioned that you know
you asked
coaches and teammates about your your
game one day they thought that you
played better maybe than the the stat
line at least offensively
said when you went back and looked at it
though what did you find
uh that you didn't think it was up your
standard and you know how did you work
to change that tonight
um defensively it was plays on defensive
end that i usually make
i was hesitant in rotations
you know they were getting a lot of easy
layouts at the rim you know officer
rebounds
so and that's all the everything energy
thing
um and so i just try to make the
adjustment to
just play free you know i know the reads
and i know that
the rotations that i have to make and
now we're all on a string tonight
but me just talking to the team and kind
of being that defensive anchor
that i always been you know just kind of
help the entire team tonight
last question lauren
hey dee uh quick question from la
i know that lebron mentioned just some
moments ago um
comparing you to or not comparing you
but um putting you in the category of
some of his former teammates and
kyrie and dwayne wade and what has the
relationship with lebron been like for
you to kind of enable you to
have the confidence and make sure that
you guys are are clicking on all
cylinders um
when you're down you know 0-1 in a
series
um and i don't i would really download
myself uh
at the game one like i said i didn't
feel like i performed to the level i
needed to
and um he let me have my moment you know
and
you know kind of get you know myself and
then uh you know he talked to me
and said i was fine which is one game
and
as a guy who's won multiple
championships and
been in the situation before he know
what to expect
he knows expect from his teammates and
you know he just kind of just was there
for me to kind of encourage me
and keep me level-headed because it it
was just one game
you know um but our relationship has
been great
you know the entire season i just kind
of just been leaning on him to
this entire scene i'm just trying to
figure out
um the the tricks and trades of of
you know playing with a guy you know
like him and
you know a team like this and it's been
it's been fun it's been great you know
the encore chemistry is clicked from day
one
uh off chemistry i mean you guys see it
all the time on social media and stuff
how close we are but um on court i never
played with a guy
you know of his caliber um and to be
able to have the success that we're
having so far
was great and just kind of you know he's
just been standing my ear about
everything especially through the
playoffs right now
you know he's seen it all 25 years he's
been playing
so so
you know he he's kind of just you know
you know been there for me and just you
know supporting me and just kind of
you know guided me through this entire
entire process
all right thanks sadie thanks heidi
thanks everyone